foreign
[Music]
calendars in the building hey
welcome welcome this is the first time
you're in our new set yep it's good to
be back here that's that's awesome wait
it's always a pleasure to have you here
on the show
and so a few weeks ago
at the same table I brought the team
together for a reaction Style video to
the news in Utah when they've banned
Bibles in schools and under that same
video a lot of people were commenting
that homeschooling is a good alternative
it's a good option for parents who are
really concerned about what's happening
in schools nowadays so I asked you to be
on the show today to help me share some
information for parents who would like
to make that transition but may not even
know where to begin what that looks like
or might be concerned you know have a
job like how can I have a job and also
homeschool my children what options are
out there and let's just jump right in
so one thing to clear up homeschooling
is legal in all 50 states now of course
according to what state you live in
there are different regulations and
guidelines that you have to follow but
many states they just require that
parents give reports
to different organizations governing
bodies called umbrella schools now here
in Tennessee there are at least 37
different institutions that you can give
these reports to and it's really just
meant to show that your child is
progressing and also you as the parent
can issue a diploma at the end of your
of your child's education which will
just will be as valid as a public school
or private school or even a GED okay and
if anyone is interested or they want to
know about the legal requirements for
your state there is an agency for that
it's The Homeschool legal Defense Agency
hslda.org and although they are the main
office is located in in Virginia they
have lawyers that are certified in every
single state so the first thing you do
you need to do is find out what the
requirements are for your particular
State we'll put those links in the
description of this video
now the transition from a child being in
Traditional School to homeschool well
it's just that it's a transition and so
you know parents need to be aware that
their child obviously has relationships
there at school that they have taken the
time to develop and build and they also
have a routine that was set in place so
transitioning to homeschooling it's a
different atmosphere and quite possibly
a different routine as well unless the
parent decides to keep the same routine
and by that I mean like waking up at the
same time breakfast and then the the the
schooling times is around the same time
or maybe they want to switch instead of
having school in the morning in the
afternoon just having that clear
communication and making a decision of
what's
the education is going to look like
going forward is really important and I
think what the education will look like
going forward depends on the parents
purpose for teaching their child at home
so when I think of homeschool I think of
home education not necessarily what is
being done in Traditional School some
people just think of public school
delivered at home right so you need to
know exactly what you want to do with
your child and once you determine where
you're going to go then from there you
will be able to craft how you go forward
and how you're going to make sure your
child benefits best
so just like uh when when you're
starting homeschool the other thing is
you should always start during after a
summer break the long break because it
gives time you give the child time to
make that transition in their thoughts
just like uh someone who's addicted to
drugs who wants to come off they're sent
to a rehab center to detox so you need
to talk
your child from traditional schools and
let them know that when you start back
their schooling or their education when
school in the new school yeah that it's
not going to be the same it's going to
be different you talk a lot about it so
they know what to expect and it's not
just a shock for them now some children
will be happy those children who learn
differently they hate school
they'll be happy and if they know they
have a say and then you're going to be
taking their interest in into
consideration they'll be happy about
that but the the traditional the
typically the child who learns in a
typical way may have a problem so know
your child and do the detox do the
d-schooling yeah during the summer
vacation
all right so you know parents
could feel overwhelmed at the prospect
of doing this so
um the idea of
I don't know I guess going from being a
parent to being a full-time teacher
what can you say to that
there is no going from one to the other
a parent is always a full-time teacher
wait wait are you saying that because
you yourself were working in the
education system so you were by
professional teacher but you're also my
mom so are you saying that because that
was your experience are you saying that
every single parent once they're a
parent is also a teacher I'm saying
every parent is a teacher a parent is
their child's first teacher you have the
child from birth to whatever time you
decide to send them to preschool or play
school could be two three four years
you're teaching that child 24 7. that
makes sense you are your child's first
and best teacher and so you don't need
to have any idea in your head that
you're not qualified you're not
certified the school systems do their
best to make parents believe that
they're not qualified to teach their own
children that's not true but I I'm not
gonna get onto my soap box I'll just
leave it there as a mother or a father
who wants to homeschool a child you are
the best teacher for your child you know
them better than any teacher in school
so no degree no problem it's okay that's
okay you're your child's teaching you
just have to have your child's interest
best interest at heart the desire to be
or to commit to being a proactive parent
that you're going to do whatever it
takes to get to know your child best
their interests their abilities and use
that to educate them okay so that would
be
I suppose the first step getting to know
your child is specifically in the
educational setting
yes well no the first step is getting to
know your child
in general okay you need to know that
your child's skills every child has a
different skill set God doesn't make any
cookie cutter person every brain is
different just as your fingerprints are
different your brain is different so
every child learns differently every
child comes with a different skill set
things that they can do well and other
things that they need a little more help
in they may be week in you need to know
your child and if you have more than one
you need to know each child right so
that you can tailor education for them
so they will get personalized education
so the objective when you're
homeschooling or when you are doing home
education is not to finish an assignment
you want your child to learn Concepts
and as they learn them and internalize
them then they are reflected in their
behavior okay so you don't want to be
rushing to finish a worksheet in fact if
you can do without worksheet to do
without them really and learn in
different ways yes so yeah if you're
doing math you need to you need a paper
on which you can do the calculations on
all of that but then you can also teach
fractions in the kitchen using a recipe
and using cooking and you can teach
reading in the supermarket with the
cereal boxes you become creative in how
you're doing it so then the child does
not have an assignment to finish within
a certain time frame they have a concept
to learn
right and they've already seen how to
apply it in all these different because
that's the thing right for at least for
me a lot of students are like why am I
learning this how am I going to use this
in life so to actually see it being used
in life while you're learning it that's
going to deepen the impression and have
a lasting effect exactly and one example
of that is I used to teach high school
geometry and the students always said to
me I don't see how I can use that this
is a useless subject so when we went to
the field one day I said okay we're
gonna walk and some of you are going to
walk the outline of the shape of the
feeling some of us are going to walk
from this corner straight across to the
other Corner what did they learn
that the straight line joining two
points
is shorter yeah than the the going
around the circumference yeah yeah so
you can teach even math you can teach
through simple life experiences and
that's what parents need to strive for
now at first
it's going to take some time there is a
learning curve you have to give yourself
Slack
so just know that and pray if you're a
Christian pray God gives you ideas you'd
be surprised at the ideas you wake up
with in the morning if you go to bed if
you pray about something and you go to
bed thinking about it you wake up in the
morning with some creative ideas I like
this quote I'd like to read it for you
our ideas of Education take too narrow
and too low or range which is kind of
what you were talking about earlier
there is need for a broader scope a
higher aim true education means more
than the pursule of a certain course of
study it means more than a preparation
for the life that is now it has to do
with the whole being
and with the whole period of existence
possible to man it is the harmonious
development of the physical the mental
and the spiritual Powers when you're
removing your child from traditional
schooling into homeschooling you're also
taking them out of that one size
fits-all type education and opening up
the possibilities so like a lot of
students they might be sitting in a big
class and either the teachers moving too
fast or the teacher's moving too slow
where they're not explaining it in a way
that makes sense and if they keep asking
questions the teachers might start
getting aggravated because she has all
or she or he has all these other
students to to give their time to so not
transitioning into the home not only are
you able to cater to that child's needs
in that area but offer holistic
education and development
and so it's just something to keep in
mind as parents are deciding what kind
of education they want to provide for
their student yeah yeah but in addition
there's just so much flexibility in
homeschooling
so if you're worried if a parent is very
worried about the child who's moving too
slowly because they have a different
learning style
or if they have a job and they figure
well I'm working how am I going to
homeschool my child
or any type of block that may come up in
your mind just think there are so many
different forms of homeschooling you
just need to make a choice of the one
that fits into your lifestyle your
family's lifestyle best yeah and we were
talking earlier about choice and how
there there's there's a solution if you
seek for it so getting frustrated or
saying you know I work so this is not an
option for me it's it's always an option
if you prioritize your child and their
development the child that God has given
you the child that you're a steward of
um you know if if this is something that
you want to do there is a way to do it
there is like with everything else what
I have learned in life is people find
solutions for what they value
just like people that how someone spends
their money tells you what they value
yes how someone spends their time also
tells you what they value so if you
value your child's
Eternal salvation you are going to pay
attention to the education because
education and Redemption are one and the
same what the child learns in school
could determine the spiritual outcome of
their life that's right so if you put
value on your child under education then
there are options out there and you can
choose one or you can choose a
combination of some you have you have
the opportunity to make your
homeschooling experience fit into your
lifestyle and your child's life so what
are some of those options that are out
there for homeschooling so there is the
co-op which is where a group of parents
come together and they decide that
they're going to educate their children
in a shared setting
and and they can decide on how that
looks
they can use one home
as the base where the other parents are
going to take their children to this one
place so the Learning Materials can stay
there and they determine the times that
they're going to do there that so you
know you have X amount of hours to do
the things at home to go to trips to go
do it and then from the hours of A to Z
on set five to seven four to six
whatever it is two to three you are
going to go to this place for your your
schooling
um or you can decide that you're just
going to rotate it among families so
they meet one week here one week there
one weekend every other week it depends
depends on you decide among yourself
with the group you can decide and co-ops
are really easy to find any church in
your neighborhood will probably have at
least one person who is in a core and
you can find information that way and
even if you're not a religious person it
doesn't matter if you're into co-ops you
can get information from a church or you
can call up schools usually school
districts have one person that's
designated for to overlook homeschooling
that's awesome okay so if you call the
school and say I'm thinking of
homeschooling my child who can I talk to
they'll direct you to that person and
then you can ask the person do you have
a list of co-ops in our area
so do the research and find a co-op one
that works for you that works best for
your family and then there is what's
called a pod now a pod is meant to mimic
a public school classroom it's for a
small group of children and it became
really popular during the pandemic
because parents wanted this great level
of control over their children whose
company were the children in so they can
control the spread of infection or that
type of thing so the families come
together they collaborate and they hire
a teacher who is going to be in one
location with a small group of children
and it presents a collective learning
environment okay
and then I have a friend who does World
schooling so it could be World schooling
or Road schooling and this is learning
on the go so these parents have a
different perspective they want location
based education they want their children
to learn about if it's Road schooling
then it's usually within your country
and you're going from state to state
from Village to Village so you want your
child to learn about the culture the the
food the habits different things so
you're teaching history and geography
just by the locations you go to if
you're doing so like you're you're going
through the Social Studies books and
you're at the site in which the book is
talking about wow okay and if you so you
had a version of that with all the
mission trips we went on so when you
were doing certain things in social
studies you had a better concept than
the other children in your class because
you have that lived experience so some
some parents decide that's the lifestyle
they want for their children in terms of
Education my friend who does World
schooling her children they go to Mexico
they go to Europe different countries in
Europe so they you can teach languages
your children can learn different
languages that way so if that's one of
your focuses then that's what you do and
and as you travel if you're doing World
schooling you're going into different
countries the amount of time you can
stay in any one country or location is
dependent on that country's government
and they lost their immigration laws and
all of that so you have to make sure
that you do your homework before you
make your plan so you don't get into any
you don't have any red tape to to go
through so that's now usually parents
who do roll um the world schooling or
Road schooling they have an online
aspect to that because there's certain
subjects that the the children would
they would subscribe to an online school
and the children complete some of their
subjects online because the focus is so
much on the lived experience right okay
so that's that and then
there is unschooling now some parents
could go to an extreme point of
unschooling and just let the child go
wild whatever the child is interested in
that's what they're going to learn
that's not the unschooling that I'm
talking about I don't call that on
schooling I I just call that wild and
crazy okay so on the on schooling I'm
referring to is more organic and it's
passion LED so you're looking at your
child you're studying your child and you
see what they are interested in and what
they learn and how they learn naturally
so you let that drive what you're
teaching them you're using the interests
and their passions to teach them all the
other things that you know they need to
learn
so you're going to focus on Hands-On
real life
experiences you're going to take them to
places that they enjoy being you're
going to be engaging them in projects
that are right in the area of gifting
their area of ability their area of
Interest
and then being spending that much time
with your kids getting to know their
interests and and seeing how they're
spending their time what they're
spending their time doing will help also
it will help the parent guide the child
as to future education Endeavors like
what to do in college I was talking to
one of the parents that I interviewed
she was saying her son was really into
photography and and just video work in
general and he would spend a lot of time
looking at tutorials getting involved in
groups and such so when she saw that and
all the time he was putting into that
and that he knew a lot already when it
came time for college she recommended he
go into business instead of video
because she's like why are you paying
for something that you've already spent
so much time learning about
go into business so you can merge the
two and become and use that you know for
the rest of your life if that's what
you'd like to do yeah but a lot of
parents might miss that if he was
spending all his time or either and not
have the opportunity to spend so much
time with that with all the school the
Traditional School load or missed that
interest because he was doing that at
school and not necessarily at home
and also the other thing with one of my
friends who
I interviewed for this also
her young daughter loves animals and she
has incorporated her own business
animals for people in their neighborhood
that's great like yesterday when I was
talking to her she was house sitting a
bunny rabbit which is perfect because
she's home that family is either at
school or at work she's home during
those times she could still get her work
done
so she learns about business she learns
her ins and outs of planning a business
registering a business making a business
plan all of these things she's learning
way younger she probably knows how to
pay her taxes already she's learning
that way younger than people because
they don't teach you those things until
you get to college and that's if you're
doing a business course right so there
there's just so much opportunity when
you decide that you're going to take
your child's education and take control
of over it and let it happen at home now
one thing I need to say about
unschooling
whereas the other forms of schooling
have documents that come with them if
you get a curriculum from an online
school there are ways of documenting
what you're teaching your children if
you're doing unschooling you have to
know you have to be able to document the
projects that you do translate them into
a format that meets your state or if you
if your child has a collagen mind the
college's requirements the educational
requirements because all of this this
freestyle education is going to be for
nothing if your child can't move forward
educationally I have some a lot of
friends who
when you talk about homeschooling they
tell you they talk about socialization
and all these other things research
actually shows that children who are
homeschooled are better in socialization
they do better at jobs
um colleges now have have scholarships
reserved for homeschooled children
because they perform better
they have a greater interest in their
education
and they get better grades they get like
20 better grades than the average
Childhood school in a regular way so all
of the myths that people have about the
the negative aspects of homeschooling
that's really not true and then of
course there's the the do-it-yourself
parent who just wants to
take the eclectic mix take some of this
some of that and create their own
program they find a curriculum that
works they take the time to develop and
find it and they use it and
homeschooler child or home educate their
child fully all right so when it comes
to finding curriculums the possibilities
are endless
finding the one that works best for your
child's learning style is the route to
go and what do I mean by learning style
there are three there's an auditory
learner it's one who prefers to hair
there's the visual learner site and the
kinesthetic learner one that likes to
move run jump or hold something tangible
in their hands to understand the concept
so when when I was in school I remember
you finding my textbooks on audio and I
would listen to them while reading it
would just help me move faster as a
visual for the visual Learners there are
tutorials a video
classroom type sessions that they can
plug into and for the kinesthetic
Learners there are programs their
curriculum set in place that
incorporates objects and movements
within the lesson to make the point now
when you're talking about learning
styles there's something that I learned
early in my training all children are
kinesthetic
up to the age of nine
okay so you want to make sure that
whatever you're teaching your child
there is some type of activity and
action that that's connected with that
concept
that's one of the reasons a lot of
children have trouble in Traditional
School
because that's right once again in the
garden and everything is all fun and
fancy and you get up and you move around
and you play with the blocks and as soon
as you get into first grade you're
expected to sit at this this this desk
on this chair and this is yeah cubicle
jail and just focus on this talking head
and so it just kills the child's
creativity because you have to focus so
much on staying still and then they
don't even want you to move around you
move around you get sent to the
principles the thing is the teacher may
have an aversion to movement that their
Vision may they may get distraction
distracted by movement and they don't
even realize that so the child who is
constantly moving why can't you keep
still not realizing the problem is not
the child the problem is you
so you you want to make sure that if
you're homeschooling you have movement
Incorporated in what you're doing
regardless of whether you think your
child prefers to hear things or to see
the information now when children get to
the age of nine usually a lot of boys
remain auditory
kinesthetic where girls move towards
being more auditory and some boys move
towards being more visual but there's a
group of boys that remain so if you have
a boy who's going to study in high
school you better allow that child to
stand by the the ironing board and write
whatever he has to write instead of
sitting at at the table to do his
written assignments if he wants to write
stand and write if he wants to kneel and
write and if you're home you have the
opportunity you have the freedom to do
all of that so which is a good point
it's not saying that your the child is
never
still or writing and things like that
just that they may need more breaks or
at least the ability to stand up they're
standing desks now instead of just the
sitting ones and that will help them
there's even desks I've seen standing
desks but uh the seat has like a foot
pedal where they could be moving their
feet while they're learning all these
different things it's not just because
you don't understand it doesn't mean
it's not important for that particular
person and so just incorporating that
and they're very quiet too
um those bicycle type chairs
incorporating that will help your child
learn yep and for some children it helps
them to concentrate for some children
they can have this distressed balls The
Squeeze balls they can have it on their
lap and why are they listening this is a
fidget spinner remember the age yeah so
I don't know how much how well those
worked but there are other things that
they can hold they can they can sit on
the exercise balls the exercise balls
now have frames you set it in a frame so
when they're sitting
there's some level of movement and it
also develops the core muscles and a lot
of children if learning problems have
weak core muscles so all of these things
there's so much available so much
knowledge if parents would just approach
homeschooling with an open mind and be
willing to learn and be creative and you
can ask your children for ideas they're
really creative you will find that you
get a lot more from your child their
their the resistance to do the things
that they can they used to think were
difficult goes away because now it's fun
and they're learning and you also have a
better opportunity of using different
strategies different learning techniques
if they're learning differently they're
now willing to try something new try it
a different way because it's a fun and
engaging way that makes sense all right
so let's get into resources and support
groups so
um Keith and his wife Rachel they you
was home Life Academy it's Nationwide
and with this group it's a
non-traditional K-12 private school for
homeschoolers offering record-keeping
Services which I thought found was
awesome academic and homeschool
counseling you're talking about like the
support system that's necessary within
homeschooling circles and documents such
as transcripts and diplomas and they
offer so much more so that might be an
option that you'd want to look up if
you're looking for like curriculums or
or support in the area of homeschooling
mom you also have something coming up
it's called The Confident parent Summit
what's that about yes so I have 16
experts in various areas who are coming
together to share their knowledge with
parents and we're really targeting
parents of children with learning
differences because what I found is that
most of the times when the parents finds
oh the child is having trouble in school
and they get them tested and they find
out okay your child has ADHD your child
has dyslexia your child has whatever the
label is that they give to this learning
difference not disability it's not a
disability it's a learning difference
whatever label they give then because of
the way the information is conveyed
parents now get so concerned all their
thinking is what program can I find or
what tutor can I hire whereas there are
certain areas of life and living that
are just as crucial like dealing with
navigating the chaos that's gonna that's
happening in your house or dealing with
the over the the overwhelm that you're
feeling because you don't know what to
do to help your child or managing your
stress managing your child's stress
they're all of these areas of life that
are so important
so I have these people coming in and
they are speaking in their area so what
I talk those three things are some of
the topics and one that I really like is
is um dealing with your child in their
area of Genius okay so supporting your
child in the area of Genius every child
is a genius and you just have to find
out your where your child's genius is so
it's all online you can watch it from
the comfort of your home you can watch
it every every day for five days next
week from Monday to Friday just coming
Monday yes July 24th through 28th it's
going to be online and how much is it
it's free yes I like that word I like
freemium it's free it's free and I know
that parents have so many expenses so
much that they need to pay money for but
they have so many needs that are not met
and they can't pay for certain things
that these people have these experts
have agreed to come and share their
knowledge freely on top of that they're
offering gifts so at the end of each
each um video at the end of each topic
that expert offers a free gift that you
can can download and yes a resource so
you can put into place the actionable
technique or tool that they talked about
you can actually do it right away and
see some results awesome okay so where
can people find that what's their
website so the website is uh The
Confident parent live l i v e.com okay
great and we'll have that below below
this video all right so other resources
is the Board of Education that's right
just because you're moving your child
from school doesn't mean that the Board
of Education isn't a resource that you
can plug into one of the parents that I
interviewed she she homeschooled her
kids her two sons from kindergarten to
fifth grade she lived in New Jersey and
Michigan in both of those States the
cities that she lived in
she connected with the board and asks
them which curriculums they were using
and then
after she taught her children the board
would send them exams the child the
children will take the exams and when
they pass them the board would Advance
her kids to the next grade so that was a
great help and as you said before the
the the the board of education has Co-op
a co-op representative yes they have
homeschooling Representatives who have
information on co-ops on other
homeschooling
um information that you need and then
for those who who have children who were
in school because someone might be
watching who they have a young child and
they're just going to start
homeschooling from the beginning but for
those who their children were in school
and they're taking them out your school
could still be a resource you can talk
to the teachers that taught your child
to learn not only the books that they're
using but also maybe what they recognize
in your child or saw as either a
learning difference or where they
excelled so you can hone in on that at
home schools also provide a place for
your child to take exams and and to join
in an extracurricular activities
not just extracurricular activities
those those
um
activities that all the children do like
music and gym and band
most of the school districts will allow
homeschoolers to come yes okay
now curriculums range in prices and
accessibility so if you're on a tight
budget I encourage you to utilize the
libraries or online thrift stores to get
the books and other resources that
you'll need and I want to make sure that
you understand when you are moving to
using a curriculum for your home
schooling
do not make the mistake of buying an
entire curriculum okay because you don't
know when when someone creates a
curriculum they do that from their own
education philosophy and it may not
align with yours so you want to make
sure that the curriculum curriculum
you're using will align with your
philosophy
and so you if you if you think you need
help in one topic
start with one
start with math start with English
whatever the the one is that you think
you may be a little weak in just start
with one and one section of it you buy
just that little piece and you try it
because then you know okay if you tried
it and it worked right good you're gonna
get some more from that but don't just
buy a whole thing and you may find that
you may need a math to buy load the math
curriculum from one company and the
English curriculum from another company
you may need to mix and match so be
careful about how you buy curriculum and
you say that yeah if you buy it in bulk
you might find the science one of no use
to you if it's full of evolution whereas
if you only bought the math from this
particular institution that's great and
then find a a creationist Institution
for Science and what have you so that's
that's a great Point yeah if your child
was in school and you're moving to
homeschooling you don't want them to
think that they're being punished
because homeschooling is actually a
blessing it's a plus it's not a
punishment that's right you want to
think of it as home education because
everything counts every aspect of life
and living counts
and so you want to explain to your child
that you're they're going to be educated
at home so they can actually learn more
than they could possibly learn in school
and they will do more of things they
like than they would ever get the
opportunity to do in a Traditional
School
and the other thing is when you are
organizing your formal sessions when you
are when you actually sit down and do
written work
plan those things when they're their
neighborhood friends are in school
you don't want the child to feel like oh
I have to be doing this and my friends
are home from school I can't go outside
to play right you don't want that to
happen
because that's one of the ways that they
they develop their social skills they
still have friends in the neighborhood
that they can play with and go to
different functions with and interact
with so you want to do that and then if
they know that if they have a date with
a friend well my friends are going to be
playing ball outside tomorrow at five
o'clock
and they have to do their schoolwork the
sit down work at two o'clock they're
gonna get it done if they're going to
develop self-discipline to make
themselves do what they need to do
within the time frame so that they can
play so play becomes a reward
if you're thinking of
beginning the homeschooling Journey
or
if you've already beguarded you just
begun and you're new
I want to encourage you to be patient
with yourself
be adaptable
because there is a learning curve
when you st when you start any new thing
there is a learning curve so
homeschooling is no different
and you want to make sure that you leave
your your mind leave yourself open to
the adjustments that you will have to
make you must make adjustments because
you're new at it and you're learning
and also give your child some leeway
the same way you're going to be open and
allow yourself time for adjusting and be
patient with your child extend the same
attitude to your child
and I want you to understand also that
it is really important to learn how your
child learns best when children discover
how they learn best they take off
they now can take ownership of their
learning because they know exactly how
they learn so spend time getting to know
how your child learns and so you can
choose the best educational approach for
them
and I want to also highlight something
we spoke about earlier
parents do not need any special
qualifications or certification to teach
their children yeah
the success of your homeschooling your
home education Journey does not depend
on a piece of paper
there are no qualifications that you
need for that
it is your god-given duty and your
stewardship uh um responsibility
that comes from God not any human who
gives you a paper
and I want to also
reiterate because we spoke about this
um when you home school your child when
you take education home you are
nurturing your child's individual
talents
so you're now giving your child a
personalized Education Without a label
because you know the children in public
school who have to get personalized
education they have to get this IEP and
individualized education plan and
they're considered to be special
education
so you can personalize your child's
education by taking them home and
teaching them and they wouldn't be they
wouldn't have to be labeled right as
some person who's less than in the
learning world or in the academic world
so nurture your child's unique strengths
and remember that you're preparing them
for success in life not to pass a test
yeah that's that's a good one no
adulterers ever asked when they went to
an interview or if they have a business
and they went to they gave a proposal
for a job no one ever asked them what
did you get on that fourth grade state
test or even Regents exams or if you're
from New York Regents exams in high
school they never ask that right so stop
your child to pass a test or
um
talking down or or scolding your child
because they didn't pass a test a test
is just feedback it just tells you what
the child learned in terms of the
concepts that were taught and what they
need more help in that's all it is
feedback just like behavior is if your
child you're homeschooling your toddler
or your your Elementary School child
Early Child second grader and the child
throws attention behavior is uh feedback
it's a symptom of an underlying problem
find out what the problem is and fix it
if you can fix it yourself get help find
support someone has had that problem
before and they know how to deal with it
so do your research find them talk to
people don't be afraid to tell people I
don't know how to teach my child math
because they don't seem to understand
the way I'm explaining it
everybody has a problem in something
every adult
has there's something that's difficult
for everyone the most brilliant person
has some area of difficulty in something
so there's no need to feel embarrassed
or ashamed
the the whole point is and this is the
last thing I'm gonna get off my soapbox
now this is good stuff you you want to
inspire greatness in your child you
don't want to kill your child's desire
to learn you want to make learning so
enjoyable
that you inspire greatness in them you
want to unleash their full potential and
create a brighter future not just for
the present but for generations to come
because you hold that power in your hand
as a parent
fantastic thank you Mama
much appreciated you're welcome and
thank you so much to the parents who who
helped me in this research I understand
I definitely know this is probably like
a drop in the ocean of all the resources
and information that is out there
um so if you are a parent or a guardian
who has homeschooled your child or other
children and you have a tip that you can
share please put that in the comments
section below and I also want to to say
these are my own opinions our own
opinions and the information we gleaned
from friends who home school there is no
hard and fast rule for homeschooling so
if in your mind you think you want to do
something different go ahead and do it
absolutely because we're not saying this
is the only way to do it we're just
talking from experience and based on our
own experience and the people that we've
spoken to we actually have a student
here in the studio who transitioned from
Traditional School into homeschooling
and so we're gonna have her come on the
show but we're going to put that behind
our pay wall so if you'd like to see
that you can go to patreon.com Little
Light Studios or you can go directly to
the low life studios website
littlelightstudios.tv and once you
donate we'll email you this episode Mom
thank you again for coming on the show
the information to your summit is the
confidentparentlive.com
calm that will be in the description as
well as the other resources we talked
about in the show and we'll see you next
time on LED it was a pleasure being here
foreign
[Music]